the CDC says there may be signs flu
activity is leveling off but the threat
is far from over the most severe flu
season in nearly a decade has taken a
heavy toll it's killed 84 children about
three-quarters of them were not
vaccinated our doctor Tara Narula shows
us how the virus can quickly turn deadly
good morning good morning so tell us why
the flu can become so dangerous a lot of
people are wondering how can it happen
so fast how can it be deadly
one of the mechanisms is pneumonia
infection or inflammation of the lungs
in the Airways either by the flu virus
itself or a bacteria that get into the
small air sacs at the end of the Airways
cause inflammation fluid to collect pass
cellular material you can no longer
exchange oxygen and carbon dioxide there
so you have low levels of oxygen in the
blood that's a problem what about if you
get sepsis sepsis is when you start off
with an infection somewhere in the body
that infection can then get in the
bloodstream and spread throughout your
body and you mount an inflammatory
response that's dysregulated your blood
pressure drops
you don't profuse your body with blood
you don't get it to critical organs that
can cause tissue damage organ failure
and death very quickly I know you say
sometimes with the flu it's almost like
the virus or your body can have a
reaction against your own body so what
if the thinking's is that for young
people who are healthy who suddenly died
from the flu it may be something called
cytokine storm your body releases
cytokines chemical messengers as part of
the defense system but the problem is
for some people we don't know why their
reaction is too much it's an
overwhelming immune reaction it then
causes damage to healthy tissue so now
you have almost like collateral damage
in a war and those healthy tissues and
the lungs can fill with fluid you can
almost drown in your own secretions so
if I'm sick how do I know when I should
take action recognize the warning signs
shortness of breath rapid breathing
rapid heart rate lethargy confusion
you're getting better and suddenly you
get worse this means you need to get to
the hospital quickly and is it getting
any better is it leveling off as they
say you know we think that it may be but
we still know that there's time to get
the vaccine if you haven't gotten it
even though the effectiveness was about
36 percent overall against in this flu
season in children six months to eight
years for h3n2 it was about 59%
effective and 75% of the kids who died
were not vaccinated so please get the
vaccine it's worth it yes thank you dr.
taryn will appreciate that